Wedged into the middle of the great
novel,
the hunchback of Notre Dame,
Victor Hugo pauses the narrative to
philosophize on the ancient significance
of architecture.
From the beginning of time he says,
cultures of the Earth wrote their
thoughts with rock.
They made words by superimposing stone
upon stone.
The Celtic Doma and chrome lack that
trust can tubulus the Hebrew Gal Gal our
words,
sometimes on a vast beach.
They join these stone words and wrote a
sentence.
The traditions had given birth
dissembles under which they disappeared
like the trunk of a tree under its
foliage and the rock symbols had need to
expand into a structure in this way he
says,
architecture developed concomitantly
with human thought reflected by the
great styles of the era and by the
political and social revolutions,
Hindu architecture gateway to
Phoenician,
Egyptian to Greek and Roman Esk to
gothic locked into the walls of these
temples,
palaces and churches.
A civilization could launch what it knew
into the future,
confident that only the greatest
upheavals and natural disasters might
dislodge it from the earth,
but as Notre Dame makes clear the gothic
period was the final page.
In this important epoch of architecture,
the advent of the printing press by
Johannes Gutenberg changed everything in
printed books,
ideas found an even more durable capsule
for transmission into posterity,
one that cost it far less to produce and
one that could be copied and sent across
the world.
The rise of the printing press mirrors
the decline of architecture as the
dominant aesthetic for on Tumbler last
week,
and this is what got me thinking about
this topic.
The Cajun Cavalier asked me what role I
thought architecture plays in society
besides that of being a defense against
the elements,
and it seems to me that these days
architecture is govern like most arts by
pluralism.
There is no consensus,
nor perhaps neither be as to a
representative style of the age arrows
that came after the sunset of the
renaissance.
We're very reactionary to the revivals
of the past and sought to create a new
aesthetic following from first the
functionalist objectivity of modernism,
and then the psychological subjectivity
of postmodernist after just major urban
expansion that greatly emphasized the
function of structures over aesthetic or
function as aesthetic.
Contemporary architectural concerns seem
largely to deal with our societies next,
great challenge,
sustainability or integration with the
environment,
and that's a concern that has to be met
with action,
but it seems to me,
and I may be wrong about this,
that there is a gross under emphasis of
the power that architecture plays on our
consciousness and culture,
the demarcation of physical spaces,
the spatial arrangement of inside and
outside.
What's communal,
what's private in an urban environment
have a massive effect on the way we see
ourselves and our place in the society
at large.
What does it mean to live in a cramped
studio apartment in Manhattan?
What does it mean to live in suburbia
among cookie cutter homes with perfect
lawns?
The utilitarian function of architecture
is so obvious that it almost disappears
into the background or rather it
disappears as the background and when we
let it do so,
when architecture becomes invisible to
us,
it's influenced for good or bad,
becomes invisible as well.
In the inner city where I lived,
demand is so high for livable spaces.
New structures are built with such
rapidity that it's impossible to imagine
any kind of central architectural theory
winning out.
That's pluralism at work tolerant but
messy,
inclusive,
but alien.
The period after postmodernism has gone
mostly undefined.
I don't know if a school of architecture
will ever again rise to cultural
predominance,
just like I don't know if we'll ever
have a classic literature with the same
weight as Shakespeare or f Scott
Fitzgerald,
but if there ever was a time Cajun
cavalier for a new architecture,
a new idea,
a new choreography of space and humanity
would be in the void of now.
Hey everybody.
Thanks for watching.
As you know,
a lot of time and research goes into the
making of these videos,
so I want to thank the good
people@audible.com
for sponsoring this one and allowing me
to do all that research and spend all of
that time.
You haven't heard about it.
Audible.com
is awesome.
They're the leading provider in audio
books with over 150,000
titles,
fiction,
nonfiction,
periodicals,
everything.
And if you go to my url,
audible.com/Evan,
you'll get a 30 day free trial and one
free audio.
That's a great opportunity to learn more
about architecture,
but in this case,
I'm going to recommend the hunchback of
Notre Dame by Victor Hugo.
Um,
it is an amazing book.
It's a classic and it's by the way,
some way darker and better than the
Disney version.
And also I,
I went to the site and check it's read
by George Dahl,
who is one of the masters of audio books
and I might just listen to it again just
to hear him do it.
They have a free app so you can download
it and put it on your phone,
which is what I usually do.
Listen to it on the subway or I'll
listen to it like in my bed before I go
to sleep.
For some reason that soothing to me.
I'm so go to audible.com/Evan.
Get the hunchback of Notre Dame on me.
I do want to mention that the idea for
this video came from the occasion
cavalier on Tumbler.
Um,
last week I did a video on video games
and all week long we were having
conversations about it,
me and all the people who watch this
video.
So I want to thank all of you.
You've been commenting in the video
below.
You've been asking me anything on
tumbler where I can sort of expand on
things a little bit more.
Um,
so keep doing that and I will see you
next Friday.